the media go nuts over a meme of
President Trump keeping a medal of
pawner to a dog drag queen story hour
goes awry in Minnesota who could have
thought and the left celebrate
censorship i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show
[Music]
the Ben Shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn protect your online privacy
today at expressvpn dot-com slash Ben oh
man we have a lot to get to today and we
begin with the most glorious story of
the day it is a glorious story because
it just exposes everything that you need
to know these days about the nature of
the mainstream media so first a preface
the mainstreaming I've been doing this
routine where they act like Amelia
Bedelia where every time somebody on the
right tells a joke they take it
extremely literally extremely late so if
you don't remember the Amelia Bedelia
books from when you were a kid or from
on your kids were kids well the Amelia
Bedelia books there's a series of books
about a character named Amelia Bedelia
who was basically a maid who took
everything extremely literally and every
idiom she would take extremely literally
so for example there's a book called
Merry Christmas Amelia Bedelia and her
boss told her to bake a date cake and so
she literally went over the calendar and
she cut out a bunch of dates and then
baked it into a cake right or she would
have an instruction in one of her in one
of her books and says dust the furniture
and so she would go and she would find
dust dusting powder in the bathroom and
then she would dust it all over the
furniture or she is told to draw the
drapes so she sits down and she draws
drapes I'm a sketchpad right that is
Amelia Bedelia where the media played
this game lately and it's an absurd
ridiculous insane game where somebody on
the right tells a joke does a satire or
headline and the media take it extremely
seriously very very seriously because
they are going to fact-check and bring
you the truth no matter that everybody
knew it was joke no matter everybody in
the world knew that it was a joke
or that it was satire instead the media
are going to treat this as though this
must be fact check so you end up with
absurdities like snobs fact-checking the
babylon bay which is an out-and-out
satire site which claims to be a satire
site it's the equivalent of Snopes
fact-checking the onion it's a Babylon
be happens to be right-wing and
Christian and orientation and in the
media are like oh well you know that's
not a big deal of course they should
fact check people could have taken that
seriously people could have taken that
seriously when the Babylon beasts had to
draw the drapes we sat down and we drew
an actual picture of the drapes
no or you would get Allie Stuckey my
friend from from the blaze TV and Allie
would do one of the fake interviews with
like a OC the same exact
sort of interview that people on Comedy
Central - all the time where they cut
themselves into interviews with people
who they would never get to book on
their show and Ally would say things and
AOC would look ridiculous and he was
obviously satire was obviously meant to
make fun of AOC and the fact that AOC
knows nothing about policy and the media
fact check ally Stuckey this was not a
satire but it was a fake news it is
doctored video doctored and fake and bad
ok well the latest iteration of the
stupidity the latest iteration of this
stupidity comes courtesy of none other
than our wonderful social media team
over at the Daily wire so first of all
shout out to our social media team at
the daily where they are just incredible
their meme game is spot-on they're
really really good at what they do so
all this week Americans have been
celebrating the heroism of a dog whose
name is now been Declassified as Conan
which is just the best so this dog that
Conan is a very very good doggie this is
the best doggie the best doggie I have
ever heard of this doggy went into a
cave after al Baghdadi rubber Bakr al
Baghdadi the head of Isis and was ready
to take down Abu Bakr al Baghdadi and
scared Baghdadi's so much that he
promptly blew himself up just
incinerated himself unfortunately two
children with him because he was an evil
piece of murderous terrorist scum okay
but Conan was in the in the cave and
Conan was slightly wounded and now Conan
is back in service and so everybody was
celebrating the heroism of this dog
because that's pretty awesome right I
mean this is the best dog ever it's a
great dog I mean this is the dog that
you ask what is best in life and the dog
replies to crush your enemies see them
driven before you and hear the
lamentations of your women and also
biscuits kibble is great also if you
have some of that so this is a great
doggy okay and as you know if you've
been listening to my show at all I am
NOT a huge dog fan I'm growing warmer to
our dogs over time my children are
twisting me into a fan of dogs but I
will say that Conan is really making me
want a dog I said as soon as Conan was
wounded that if Conan needed an owner I
would be happy to become a dog person
and adopt Conan because this is the best
dog you okay so the daily wired social
media team who listen to the show and
then very often create memes that are
kind of drawn from the general themes of
the show they put out a meme and the
meme was a picture of President Trump
awarding the medal of pawner pawner to
the dog right and so they took
a picture of President Trump awarding a
medal of honor to a to an American hero
named James McLaughlin who is credited
with saving the lives of 10 men in a
battle in Vietnam and this this photo
had nothing to do with mcLaughlin
okay like McLaughlin the last thing that
the Daily wire would ever think of doing
is to riding an actual war hero of
course of course and nobody actually
thinks that's what the daily where
social media team was doing with are
they really suggesting that this was
meant to dishonor the person who was the
center of the photo no the Taylor we're
soaps with me good team took this photo
and they just put in the dog right they
obviously photoshopped in the dog so
it's a president Trump pudding not the
Medal of Honor
it's a medal that has a picture of a paw
print on it on the dog obviously
obviously photoshopped it has our
watermark in the bottom right hand
corner of the picture okay nobody's
trying to hide the ball here
this is just the cute little tributes to
a very good doggy that's all it's a joke
and a cute little tribute to a very good
doggy
and so President Trump sees this and he
thinks it's cute because you know Trump
this is one of the charming things about
Trump there are many things that are not
charming about Trump one of the
wonderful charming things about Trump is
that when the man sees something that he
enjoys he sort of just puts it out there
so he put out our picture with the
watermark in the right-hand corner of
himself giving the medal of honor to the
dog and I pointed out again that it's
obviously photoshopped that obviously he
did not give a medal of honor to a dog
there's no such thing as a medal of
honor the actual metal is not the Medal
of Honor look look at the photo if
you're subscribing you can see or if
you're watching this live you can see it
is a picture of a paw print okay the
President Trump then tweets out American
Hero American Hero now this should be
the end of the story right it's just
kind of like a cute funny little tweet
but no our intrepid media are on the
case they are on the case so the
Washington Post and The New York Times
and USA Today and pretty much everybody
else covers this as though it's actual
news and as though it's a scandal not
just the president Trump tweeted out a
meme but that it's a real scandal here's
the headline from the intrepid reporters
at the New York Times they put two of
their finest on at Niraj of chalk she
and Karen's rake came their headline is
Trump tweets faked photo of hero dog
getting a medal faked photo faked but
lick was
like a faked photo would be something
where there was any pretense at realism
any pretense at trying to fake out the
audience fake photos sort of assumes
that we are attempting to fake you into
believing something this is just called
a funny meme I do not do not even meme
bro like this is the most obvious joke
and tribute ever ever ok the New York
Times reports it this way President
Trump on Wednesday shared an altered
photograph of himself placing a medal
around the neck of the dog injured in
the raid last weekend that led to the
death of Abu Bakr al-baghdadi the
Islamic states leader well in altered
photographs oh it's fake news it's bad
information President Trump trying to
cede the ground that he likes a dog that
was involved in the killing of Abu Bakr
al-baghdadi Wow Wow I mean what what a
get what a get guys well done New York
Times that is some extensively amazing
journalism just unbelievable journalism
he tweet you mean he tweeted out a photo
of himself giving a fake medal to a
doggie to a very good doggie this is
your big story you idiots
okay then they continue along this the
image which bears a watermark for a
social media account for the
conservative news site The Daily wire
appear to be an altered version of a
2017 Associated Press photograph in the
original mr. Trump is seen awarding a
Medal of Honor to James McLaughlin and
retired Army medic who's credited with
saving the lives of 10 men during the
war in Vietnam and present then they
quote President Trump talking about how
wonderful the dog is and then they talk
about mcLaughlin and suggest that Trump
is trying to ride the veteran who was
simply in that photo right I mean it was
not again no one Trump Daily wire no one
is trying to dishonor the person who won
the medal of honor that's insane for you
to believe that you have to be such a
wretched toolbag of a human being like
of course that's not what any who strive
to do but the media tried to twist this
into this isn't Lane McLaughlin knows
this right McLaughlin was called it by
the New York Times in a phone interview
on Wednesday McLaughlin 73 who had not
seen the image before a reporter send it
to him said that he interpreted it as
mr. Trump recognizing the dog's heroism
he certainly was not offended and
laughed when he compared the two images
of course because McLaughlin is a normal
human being you stupid tools of course
look what the hell is wrong with you
people
what is wrong with you because McClung
like to be offended by that you'd have
to be you have to be wrong in a head you
have to be wrong in the head to be
offended by all of this right and and
McLaughlin said after all Medal of Honor
recipients accept on behalf of their
entire teams especially those that did
not return from battle and canines have
long been part of war efforts he said
this recognizes the dog is part of that
team of brave people McLaughlin said he
had worked with the dog in Vietnam who
helps detect enemy activity during
missions they are very courageous he
said of military canines quick come on
come on
okay so that was the New York Times
coverage but it gets even better wait
until you hear the Washington Post
coverage which is even worse
and again this is a story that the media
treated as a national story they treated
as an actual national story that Donald
Trump tweeted out a meme of himself
awarding a hero dog they treated as a
national story again the story gets
better guys it gets so much better we'll
get to that in just one second first
let's say that you don't feel like
taking all these packages that you want
to send off for christmas or hanukkah
it's it's that Thanksgiving season yeah
bunch of packages want to see them in
the mail but you don't feel like taking
all that stuff putting in the back yard
car schlepping it to the post office
post office is great but who wants to
spend the time and the effort and the
energy instead you could do all of this
from home and get all the amazing
services of the US Postal Service
directly from your computer this is
where stamps come comes in I mean this
is why the internet was invented folks
stamps.com
allows you whether you're a small office
handing invoices or an online seller
shipping out products or a warehouse
setting thousands of packages a day
stamps allows you to handle it all with
ease
stamps.com allows you to use your
computer to print official US postage
24/7 any letter any package any class of
mail anywhere you want to send it once
your mail is ready you just hand it to
your mail carrier or you drop it in a
mail box it is indeed that simple with
stamps calm you get five cents off every
first-class stamp up to 40% off Priority
Mail it's a no-brainer so really don't
spend your time slipping stuff to the
post office this holiday season instead
head on over to stamps comm right now
there's no risk my promo code Shapiro
allows you to get a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus free
postage and the digital scale which is
an awesome deal no long term commitments
no contracts using our code you'll be
saving money and supporting the show
that's always important obviously let
the advertisers know we sent you go to
stamps com click on that microphone at
the top of the homepage type in at
Shapiro that stamps com
enter promo code Shapiro stamps calm
never go to the post office again okay
so the story gets even better
hey the story gets even better the story
from Alex Horton reporter at the
Washington Post
okay so first note Alex Horton
apparently is an Iraq war veteran
nothing but respect for his military
service also this is insanely bad
reporting okay so two things can be true
once Alex Martin can be an American
patriot who served honorably in Iraq
also he can be an unbelievably crappy
reporter so here's his report from the
Washington Post the headline says Trump
tweeted a photo of a Medal of Honor
recipient who was edited out and
replaced by a dog by a dog oh no then it
says in a somber White House ceremony in
July 2017 president Trump draped the
Medal of Honor around the necks of James
the neck of James mcLaughlin
he was credited with saving the lives of
ten men in a brutal day's long battle in
Vietnam and Trump told the former Army
medic that we are in awe of your actions
and your bravery on Wednesday Trump
posted a photo of that moment with
McLaughlin's image replaced by that of a
dog the distinctive star of the medal
was replaced with a paw print Trump in
the Pentagon declined to release the
dog's name but the canine has since
become a social media sensation after
Trump tweeted a photo of the dog on
Monday since then the dog has been a
feature of countless memes it also
collided with a real world moment after
the conservative site daily wire tweeted
the image Tuesday with McLaughlin
removed a watermark that the site
appears in Trump's tweet but it is
cropped version that removes the
attribution of the source photo which is
The Associated Press that's because the
source photo has now been dramatically
altered the source photos did not
include a dog or a medal of porn are you
idiots it's called the meme this hell
means work on the interwebs that would
have indicated it began as a legitimate
news photo raising the question of
whether Trump or a staffer knew
McLaughlin had been edited out okay so
I'm pretty fairly certain that Trump
knew he had not actually awarded the
Medal of Honor to a dog I'm fairly
certain that Trump knew this now even if
you thought that Trump may have
forgotten that he awarded the Medal of
Honor to a dog I feel like he would have
known that it wasn't real once he looked
and saw a medal of pawner
it's a paw on the medal you dolt okay
here's where the story gets great hey
and then it says a White House spokesman
declined to comment
McLaughlin 73 could not be reached for
comment well actually he could
near times just didn't respond to you
and then this is the best part
Jeremy boring the chief operating
officer at the daily we're dismissed
emailed questions about whether the
altered photo originated from his
publication okay this is the part that's
totally insane
so Jeremy who is my longtime business
partner and chief operating officer at
say Lee Weyer founder a co-founder of
daily wire he did loose in that sense
again dismissed emailed questions about
whether the altered photo originated
from his publication okay first of all
number one our watermarks on it it's
like right there in Trump's original
tweet but that the way that's reported
sounds like boring dismissed question
like he wouldn't be refused and we at
the daily where we were so scared of the
question we refused to answer the
question as to whether the altered photo
originated from our publication we just
refused because some men because this is
a scoop guys it's a scoop okay well
here's how the actual exchange went Alex
Wharton emailed our social media team he
said hello I'm what the Washington Post
and I wanted to get confirmation this
photo originated with you and if you
digitally removed
Medal of Honor recipient James
McLaughlin and replaced him with a dog
okay and Jeremy responded the way that
any normal human being would respond it
is a pretty epic response to wrote back
Alex on the record you've got to be
effing joking please quote me on that
thanks Jeremy we jokingly called Jeremy
the god-king but he definitely was it
was great there that's that's
spectacular stuff from Jeremy you've got
to be effing joking please quote and by
the way I didn't see this in some like
hours later today I'm over here in
Israel and this is just the best you've
got to be effing Joe because correct
you've got to be effing joking your fat
checking whether a photo of a dog being
awarded the medal of pawner is real
you're expending reporter dollars on
this stuff what what and then it was
reported by The Washington Post as
Jeremy dismissed emailed questions about
whether no he didn't dismiss emailed
questions he dismissed her stupid
question he dismissed you he didn't
dismiss the question he dismissed you he
said you've got to be like there's no
way to read that as Jeremy saying you
know we have no comment we issued no
comments all died here at Daily wire
like it's it's a big
everybody does in the media that happens
if we wanted to no comment you know we
could have done no comment
instead Jeremy explicitly said please
quote me you have to be please quote me
you have to be effing joking correct
correct
but I'll get to the deeper theme humanik
here because there actually is something
deeper and kind of disturbing here in
this story it's embedded in a very funny
story but there is something that is
well worth discussing I'm gonna get to
that in just one second but first you
know you walk into your home sometimes
and you like I replace the furniture
repainted the walls but something still
exceed in she about this place well
probably it's cuz you haven't thought
about the window coverings who thinks
about window coverings on a routine
basis but good blinds are to a home what
a sharp tie is to a suit it brings
everything together going blind shopping
is not something that I dream about
doing a month oh man and get up today
I'm gonna go blind shopping but if you
go to blinds calm you can make it really
fast and really easy which is why I
enjoy using blinds calm with fifty
million windows covered and over thirty
thousand five star customer reviews
blinds calm is America's number one
online retailer for affordable quality
custom window coverings blinds comm
makes the whole experience fast and easy
plus every order gets free samples free
shipping and a free online design
consultation it blinds are a simple
effective way to make your home more
beautiful and light as that con makes it
super easy so the pictures of your home
and then they send back custom
recommendations for you from a
professional they'll send you free
samples and if you screw it up and if
you accidentally miss measure you pick
the wrong color blinds that tumble then
remake the blinds for free so I mean you
really have nothing to lose here for a
limited time my listeners get 20 bucks
off at blinds calm when you use promo
code Ben that's blinds.com promo code
Ben for $20 off for wood blinds cellular
shades roller shades and more blinds
compro mclubbe Ben rules and
restrictions do apply ok so president so
so all of this becomes an issue by the
way I also tweeted back at the and so I
tweeted out all of this right tweeted
out this is this entire exchange and
then I I added and then I added I said
so Washington Post asked my business
partner Jeremy boring about our Medal of
Honor Dawg me his glorious responses
screen cap below their report then
suggested Jeremy refused to answer
questions about the picture um no we
think you're being effing insane and
then
I added yes we created the meme yes it
is a joke yes
you people are also jokes please feel
free to quote both me and Jeremy hunt
this because of course of course
okay so then president Trump takes it to
the next level which is just this is
best Trump I love it
this is best Trump so President Trump
and tweets out Thank You daily wire very
cute recreation but the live version of
Conan will be leaving the Middle East
for the White House sometime next week
which is great it's a very good doggy
like what do you how do you somehow end
up on the wrong side of the very good
doggy debate it's a very good doggy like
why are you why are you upset about
things that are paying tribute to a very
good doggy
your stupid tools what like why why how
how and then all of these people acting
as though Photoshop is a new thing oh my
god have you seen it's an to faked
altered photo it's not a deep fake okay
it's not like a deep fake of some
matinee idol having sex with somebody
for pornographic purposes it's not a
deep fake of Barack Obama saying a thing
he didn't say it's not even an altered
video attempting to skew things in any
way it is literally just a meme and
somehow the media ended up on the wrong
side of this one person online was
tweeting out photos very funny of
president Rimmer there's that photo of
President Trump on the White House lawn
like yelling at a kid who's mowing the
lawn see tweeted out a photo of
President Trump yelling at the dog
saying are you photoshopped and like
that's that's what this is it's so
unbelievably stupid and I'm looking
forward to the media fact-checking all
jokes actually like I can't wait for it
like we definitely need the media to
fact-check knock-knock jokes like were
you aware that when someone tells you a
knock-knock joke they're not actually
standing outside your house knocking on
the door were you aware fat check fat
check were you aware that chickens
whacked the requisite intent to even
know really why they're crossing the
road so all of those why did the chicken
cross the road jokes they're irrelevant
because the chicken doesn't know why
it's crossing the road it doesn't have
the requisite intent media fact check
and what the hell is wrong with you
people
so I treated back at president from know
Thank You mr. president
and say hello to a very good doggie for
us because everyone has lost their mind
they've lost their damn mind but there
is a deeper point here okay in the
deeper point here is that what the media
are doing and they keep doing this is
the
broadening the scope of what they now
consider quote-unquote - disinformation
right anything that they don't like any
joke any meme any piece of funny satire
they now take seriously like Amelia
Bedelia specifically so they can men
label the outlet that promotes that
content as somehow as somehow dealing in
misinformation in lies right this is
their thing they've as I say they did it
to the Babylon be they've done it to
Allie Stuckey over at plays TV and now
they're doing it with regard to an
obvious name with a dog receiving the
medal of pawner right this is this is
what they are doing and this has
real-world ramifications because what
the left is doing is they're making a
very simple argument that has very large
real world around suggestions this is
just kind of the outline stupid case
point okay but what the left is
attempting to do is they're attempting
to say that this information has so
radically skewed the way that the
American public views information that
the government needs to step in and stop
people from exercising the First
Amendment we had an article like this by
Richard Spang Richard spangle Spangler
over at former Time magazine editor and
Obama administration State Department
official in an article like that from
him in the Washington Post just two days
ago right that happened just a couple of
days ago and now you have the media
pressuring Facebook and Twitter to shut
down free dissemination of speech in the
name of shutting down disinformation so
what they do is they keep broadening the
definition of disinformation to
encompass anything they don't like so
you have an article in The Washington
Post by Charlie Juarez Oh claiming that
Breitbart should not be included in
Facebook's news feed right yes CNN
yes Huffington Post no Breitbart why
because that's misinformation or distant
howl do we know that well I mean you can
check Snopes packs checks them all the
time and it doesn't matter that Snopes
also fact checks selectively only
right-wing outlets and half the time the
soaps fact checks are wrong that doesn't
matter the idea is to create a narrative
and there it is that if you see content
from a right-wing outlet that it should
be shut down and is not a legitimate
exercise of the First Amendment and so
you're seeing members of the media I'm
old enough to remember when there was a
very famous case called New York Times
versus Sullivan and it was all about the
rights of the media to print material is
all about slander and libel and the
standards for printing material publicly
and the New York Times is on the right
side of that fight is about broadening
the First Amendment members the media
used to be very much in favor
of broadening the First Amendment of
recognizing a joke for a joke of trying
to actually suss out facts rather than
create fake controversies of the day for
clickbait t anti-trump material right
that was like what five minutes ago
ten minutes ago when this was supposedly
their top priority now they've shifted
now they've shifted and so what you see
is this vast push by the by the left to
go after right-wing outlets and say that
they are in fact fake news who should be
banned because they are disseminating
this information or to go after Donald
Trump's political campaign and say that
Trump's political campaign should not be
allowed to post ads because if they post
ads the ads might contain information
that the left finds to be false or
twisted cuz it's called the campaign ad
right but they don't want that or you'll
see them say well thanks to Russian
interference in the 2016 election we
need to use government to crack down on
big tech and prevent the dissemination
of information to understand there's
only one type of information that the
left truly cares about preventing
dissemination of and that's anything
that opposes their agenda because we're
all on the same page when it comes to
the Russians disseminating
misinformation nobody wants that I don't
want that you don't want that Facebook
doesn't want that Twitter doesn't want
that nobody wants that but that's not
the real agenda the real agenda is shut
down all the speech I don't like shut
down the quote unquote
hate speech I don't like shut down the
political speech that I feel like is
misinformation sure it may be factually
correct but it's but it's it's just it's
couched the wrong way I'll get to the
real-world example of this happening
over at the New York Times again used to
be the bastion of free speech but not
anymore we'll get to that in just one
second first let's talk about
communication and communication in
marriage is extremely important but in
certain topics it's kind of challenging
one of those topics is sex well if you
are suffering from erectile dysfunction
you know the fact is that you may feel
the necessity to keep that kind of
secret it's kind of embarrassing but you
need to get it solved so what do you do
you head on over to Roman with Roman you
can get a free online evaluation and
ongoing care for eg all from the comfort
and privacy of your home the doctor will
then work with you to find the best
treatment plan if medication is
appropriate Roman will ship it to you
with free two-day shipping the whole
process is straightforward and simple
and discreet getting started is really
simple just go to get Roman comm slash
Ben and come
and online visit erectile disfunction
used to be tough to tackle now there is
rhomin complete an online visit today to
connect with the doctor and take care of
it just go to get Roman comm slash been
to get a free online visit in free
two-day shipping that's get Roman comm
slash man for a free visit to get
started
GE t ro ma n comm slash man you got a
medical problem just get a medical
solution rather than letting
embarrassment keep you in a bad position
go check them out at get Roman comm
slash Ben get Roman comm slash Ben okay
so what are the real-world ramifications
of all this it's the call by members of
the media to shut down dissemination of
political information on social media
websites it's the call by members of the
media and some members of the Obama
administration to actually curb the
First Amendment and rewrite it and the
way that again that they broaden this
out is to is to go after even stupid
examples of quote unquote fake news like
a meme of the president tweeting out
himself giving a fake medal to a dog
ready you just keep broadening this
thing out that's the goal here
and so here's where you end up yesterday
Twitter said it would ban all political
ads ban all of them there's it out right
now the left is celebrating why what's
is celebrating because they know that
they own the means of distribution that
are not the main social media platforms
meaning that if you want to get any sort
of non left news the best places to get
that online our places that used to be
sort of online public forum right places
like Twitter or places like Facebook or
places like YouTube and so what the left
really wants they're happy with banning
all political ads and say oh this isn't
politically motivated they're banning
all political ads and we're happy about
it no you just know that the political
ads are then going to be distributed and
disseminated in the form of the New York
Times or CBS or CNN or all of the other
outlets that you guys have the Internet
has radically decentralized the methods
for disseminating information radically
decentralized it the Internet has made
it possible for you to access
information in a way you wouldn't before
right you get to watch this show you get
to see this show you get to read our
stuff a Daily wire you can follow us on
Facebook you can follow me on Twitter
the goal of the left would be okay you
know what if we have to be on like all
political speech on these platforms and
force people to not engage in political
speech we can live with X if we go back
to the old system we were dominant under
the old system which is
the left media war dominance under the
old system the New York Times would love
nothing better nothing better than to
shut down the dissemination of
information in places like Facebook and
Twitter and YouTube they would love
nothing better than that why because
they have legacy media branding people
still know who the New York Times is
it's a barrier to entry to get rid of
the social media methods of distribution
of information and the New York Times
knows that they don't want competition
they want to be the only game in town
and the way you ensure you're the only
game in town is you basically make it
very difficult for people to disseminate
information through publicly available
for us so Twitter went along with the
game because Twitter is a horrible
outlet run by a guy who is on the very
far left and has no principles about
free speech as in none Jack Dorsey
apparently so Twitter said on Wednesday
it would ban all political ads putting a
spotlight on the power and veracity of
online advertising and ramping up
pressure on Facebook's chief executive
Mark Zuckerberg to reverse his hands-off
stands yeah well Jack Dorsey is probably
also willing to kowtow to the Chinese
when it comes to censoring Twitter so he
had exactly a free speech warrior Dorsey
said political ads including manipulated
videos and the viral spread of
misleading information presented
challenges to civic discourse all at
increasing velocity sophistication and
overwhelming scale
he said he worried the ads had quote
significant ramifications that todays
democratic infrastructure may not be
prepared to handle he added he believed
the reach of political messages should
be earned not bought okay now this is
his way of saying I'm not a real
capitalist really Jack give up your
stock really the idea here is that you I
prize civility over over money shut down
your website man let me tell you
Twitter's a cesspool any time you feel
like giving up that stock it is all you
make the magic happen but the fact is
that Jack Dorsey has no intent of doing
any of that this is virtue signaling to
the left and not only is it virtue
signaling to the left it is an attempt
to appease a left that wishes to see
speech narrowed rather than broadened
I've seen many political ads for
Democrats on Twitter I think a lot of
them are steeped in false information do
I think that Twitter should stop running
those ads no I think that it's my job to
critique those ads I think there's
millions and millions of people on
Twitter who can then discuss whether the
ads are true or false and just promoting
an ad on Twitter just like any other
political
pain isn't it preventing that is insane
by the way this is it sort of the
equivalent of what the left commonly
does when you talk about campaign
finance reform so we talk about campaign
finance reform they're like look at
these big bad terrible donors they're so
big and they're so bad and they're so
terrible also you know who we should
allow to have more power the unions
right the unions should have more power
and media should have more power so I
shouldn't be able with my friends to
form a super PAC to put out political
advertising information I shouldn't be
able to spend my own money to
disseminate information or for example
buying an ad in the New York Times with
my super PAC but the New York Times
should be able to run whatever it wants
on its front page over and over and over
and also unions should probably be able
to do that though all animals are equal
except for the pigs this is the way that
the Left wishes to treat discourse in
the United States so of course they're
very happy with Twitter shutting this
down because they understand that
Twitter is never going to shut down
leftist political messaging on Twitter
Twitter will ban people for saying that
a man is not a woman but Twitter will
never ban somebody for saying the
opposite Twitter will ban political
advertising knowing full well that
Twitter also tends to promote leftist
causes and leftist politicians so of
course the left is happy about this but
the media is setting this up is a clash
of principle you know what it is a clash
of principle it turns out that some of
these outlets want more speech and some
of these outlets want less speech and
it's kind of amazing for Twitter a
supposed free speech outlet to be
curbing political ads in the name of
we're going to fact check it now who
died and appointed you the great
arbiters of truth over at Twitter you
guys are a joke when it comes to our
bidding truth over at Twitter I mean I
can't even count the number of false
headlines that Twitter has run in its
trends over the last nine months about
me personally so know you guys aren't
the arbiters of truth you're just a
you're just a bunch of leftist who are
motivated to push a particular point of
view and the New York Times is super
happy about this and they say Twitter's
announcement it would eliminate
political ads starting November 22nd
prompted immediate attacks from the
right red par scale mr. Trump's campaign
manager for the 2020 election said
Twitter's decision was a partisan act
intended to silence conservatives and of
course that is true Democrats of course
praised a Twitter AOC who is happy to
disseminate as much information as
humanly possible via her well followed
account previous Twitter and said if a
company cannot or does not run to wish
to wish to run basic back checking on
paid political advertising they should
not run paid political ads at all
how about this how about we run basic
fact-checking on your tweets and then if
they don't meet basic fact-checking
notions then you get banned from Twitter
how about that how about we stop your
crap tweets that very often are steeped
in the absolute falsehood how about that
but it seems to me that all those are
still up your buddy Ohana Omar put out
an absolutely false tweet about a kid
dying who isn't dead the other day and
then she just put like a little addendum
that thing's still up
it's amazing how so many members left
our sanguine with the inability of
people to disseminate information why
because they know that they always will
be able to they say that they even even
Biden's campaign is saying this is
ridiculous right bill Russo a spokesman
for Joe Biden's campaign so it was
unfortunate
to suggest the only way to deal with
false claims in political ads was not to
run the ads at all but he added it was
encouraging that for once revenue did
not went out ah so the anti capitalism
outweighed the free speech principle so
they were all good with the free speech
we can disseminate what you want until
it turned out that you were paying to
put stuff on Twitter oh wow because as
we all know people on Twitter they don't
any money for being on Twitter and they
don't spend hours being paid to be on
Twitter which by the way is what every
major media figure does why do you think
a OCS on Twitter because it's good for
her brand and this is this is all a it's
a concerted attempt to shut down the
ability to disseminate information by
broadening out the fact checking the
fact-checking abilities of the media
into areas that are completely false
it's gaming the system in other words
and the left is fond of doing it and now
they're trying to leverage it against
Facebook and as I say you get complete
anti free speech fools like Harris
Swisher writing pieces on this today at
the New York Times your move of Facebook
is what Kara Swisher writes by the way
the other day she suggested she would
like to head up the appeals board over
at Facebook so she could determine what
stuff to kick off this is the same Kara
Swisher who in a conversation with Susan
watch kicky suggested that she would
love nothing better said I can't I
understand you can't really do it but I
would love nothing better than to see
ben shapiro booted from youtube because
my son watches his videos hey I
definitely trust her with free speech
I've never suggested the Kara Swisher
should lose her job or be booted off
social media or be restricted in any way
from disseminating her content but this
lady is the greatest and wisest among us
who is going to dictate how you get your
information so it starts off with like
these simple stupid fringe stories about
the media going nuts over a doggy photo
but that's not really what this is about
but this is
really about is exaggerating the threat
of misinformation assuming that you are
a who is incapable of assessing
your own sources of information and then
saying what you know what I understand
you're dumb you're doesn't mean that you
didn't get that that dog photo wasn't
real you didn't get it cuz you're dumb
so here's what I'm gonna do I'm going to
stop all that information from even
hitting your eyeballs instead you'll see
the stuff that I think is true normally
we would call the censorship on the left
this is called freedom of speech because
language has been completely inverted
they will get some more of this in just
one second first let's talk about your
sleep quality so I am abroad right now
and that means I am desperately missing
my Helix sleep mattress I'm slipping on
a mattress it ain't great my sleep
quality has not been fantastic but helix
sleep when I get back I am I am lying on
that helix sleep mattress after that 16
hour flight and I am just going to doze
it's gonna be fantastic why well helix
sleep personalizes a mattress for you
right we live in a personalizing of
product time and helix sleep is at the
very forefront of this helix sleep has a
quiz it takes just two minutes to
complete it matches your body type and
sleep preferences so the perfect
mattress for you no matter how you sleep
on your side on your back hot sleeper
whatever helix can make what your body
needs just go to helix sleep calm slash
Ben take their two minutes sleep quiz
and they will then match you to a
customized mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life for couples
helix can even split that mattress down
the middle providing individual support
needs and feel preferences for each side
I've got a 10 year warranty you get to
try it out for 100 nights risk-free
they'll even pick it up for you if you
don't love it but you definitely will
check out helix sleep comm /ban for up
to 125 bucks off your mattress order
again helix sleep comm slash bond Ben
and get 125 bucks off they've got a 10
year warranty by the way so again and
and you get to try it out for a hundred
nights was great you really have nothing
to lose check them out helix sleep comm
slash man ok we have much more on this
topic plus the extent to which
censorship is being taken by the left I
mean this is a scary time for the First
Amendment and for free speech attitudes
in general forget about government
censorship for free speech attitude is a
very dangerous time in the country we'll
get to more of that in just one second
first head on over to Daily wire calm as
I've been saying this entire show the
left wants to use these social media
platforms who shut down information that
you want and that you need and this is
why you should go subscribe over a daily
wire there are too many people on the
Left who would like to deep platform
daily wire who would like to deep
platform me would like to deep platform
our other hosts
this is their goal in life they spend
every waking moment trying to figure out
how they can go after our advertisers
how they can convince social media
outlets to dump us
hey this is their thing the way that you
fight back again said I get all sorts of
letters how do I fight back against left
honestly it sounds self-serving and in a
way it is but the fact is we are
bringing you information that you want
obviously that's why you're listening to
the show go subscribe over at daily wire
com $9.99 a month or 99 bucks a year
brings you this the very greatest in
beverage vessels the leftist year is hot
or cold tumblr I also want to remind you
that the Daily wires app is finally here
and it is fantastic I mean it's really
great if you're a subscriber you can now
access all of our contents including
articles and q and A's and all the good
stuff when you just download that app
all access subscribers get the new
exclusive discussion features you can
talk with me you can talk with our
writers our other hosts the app is
available on Apple and Android so
download it today become a subscriber
come join the fun plus if you subscribe
you also get our fantastic Sunday
special on Saturday this week's sunday
special features Peter Robinson who is
over at the Hoover Institute and also
happens to be the guy who wrote the tear
down this wall mr. Gorbachev that speech
so go check that out it really is
fantastic
this is his pet peeve of mine we're not
allowed to say that
our side won the Cold War it just ended
well
let me point out one thing the United
States is still here in the Soviet Union
what defunct we want it's really
first-rate stuff I think you're gonna
love it
check it out this Saturday if you're a
subscriber or Sunday if you are not also
go check us out over at over at daily
we're calm please subscribe we really
appreciate it we're the largest
fastest-growing conservative podcast and
radio show in the nation
[Music]
so walks golden chief and sensor Kara
Swisher has peace entirely about this
today called your move Facebook Twitter
will no longer allow political
advertising a move that places Twitter
and Jack Dorsey in stark contrast to
Facebook and Mark Zuckerberg that's one
small step by Jack one giant leap for
tweet kind it's not as significant as a
man conquering space yes he a man
conquering space was about achieving
something this is about shutting down
political speech so yeah those aren't
those aren't the same it turns out but
Twitter's chief executive check Dorsey
moon walked into the digital future on
Wednesday with a move that was both
unexpected and inevitable in a Twitter
threat of course he declared that the
company would no longer allow political
advertising on Twitter globally well why
not just extend it why don't you say no
political speech on Twitter globally
because you know the next step it's
going to be that powerful people in the
media on the right are quote-unquote
disseminating false information they
need to be kept off Twitter that is the
next step it starts with the paid
political stuff because after all they
can rip Twitter for being corporate
driven and profit driven but it's not
gonna stop there Kara Swisher has made
clear over and over she doesn't want it
to stop there to those hoping that mr.
Dorsey would also take action against
one of the platform's most famous rules
violators let's make one thing clear
Donald Trump can still huff and puff
away on his disingenuous digital
sousaphone but his campaign cannot pay
to do so still it was a book says she
wants Trump kicked off Twitter and she's
not even hiding the ball here she's
still it was a bold and epic poke that
seemed to aimed directly at Mark
Zuckerberg since Twitter's announcement
came just as Facebook was dropping its
current earnings report while Facebook's
earnings were spectacular especially in
comparison to Twitter's weaker showing a
week ago the announcement now places
Twitter and Dorsey in stark contrast to
the social networking giant and its
co-founder and CEO why well mr.
Zuckerberg said in a disastrous series
of recent appearances in Washington DC
his huge platform would not only keep
accepting political ads but also would
allow politicians who eye in them well
with Zuckerberg said is it's your job to
fact-check and it's my job not to shut
down speech which is called freedom
coincidence actually it feels like the
best sub tweet ever it is yet another
example like last year's widespread Z
platforming of conspiracy troll Alex
Jones of social media not only starting
to clean itself up but beginning to
understand the major responsibilities it
has to the well-being of society at
large well beyond just making money
bullcrap here's what happened Hillary
Clinton lost in 2016
you guys were pissed he blamed Russian
trolls and quote-unquote disinformation
instead of yourselves running a crap
candidate you're very angry that Donald
Trump is president and now you're going
to take it out on all of the outlets and
ask them and then demand that they and
then push them to D plan from everybody
you don't like your response to losing
an election is that you don't like the
principles that underlie American
elections on a fundamental basis that is
what is going on here you have a similar
article from Thomas Friedman in the New
York Times called Trump Zuckerberg and
pals are breaking America now what does
Trump have to do with Zuckerberg they
apparently don't even like each other so
what exactly do they have to do with
each other
apparently Zuckerberg is a problem why
because he's allowing political ads to
run on Facebook you know because
dissemination of information is good
more information is better more debate
is better the Friedman says this is all
about money for Zuckerberg as opposed to
Thomas Friedman who gives all of his
salary to charity who works for the New
York Times for free and just runs around
the globe writing best-selling books on
on his own dime I mean what what a giver
he is profit profit Oh terrible profit
or alternatively Mark Zuckerberg has
given up an awful lot of profit by not
actually allowing his service to be
available in China just so he would not
have to bow to the Chinese censors have
not heard the same about Twitter so
there it is
I mean it's just it's absurd it's absurd
Friedman says Yeah right as if average
American citizens are able to discern
the veracity of every political ad after
years of being conditioned by
responsible journalism to assume the
claims aren't just made-up what does
that even mean basically you believe
that people can't make decisions on
their own about the veracity of
information they're all more they're all
idiots and morons I'm like Thomas
Friedman who's been taken in by regimes
including the Iranians and the Chinese
and who wrote a column several years ago
suggesting the one-party democracy in
China may be more effective than
two-party democracy in the United States
Thomas Friedman should definitely
determine what sort of information you
can see it this is the stuff that's
scary and then they use Russia as the
front right all these conversations
always start with Russian disinformation
again we all agree Russian
disinformation bad foreign countries
interfering in American elections bad
agree agree but that's not where it ends
it doesn't start with you know what we
really need to find these sort of
Russian
account and shut them down because
that's interference by a foreign
government we shouldn't allow that it
turns very quickly into we need to stop
Trump from running ads and then it turns
very quickly into Trump should be banned
from the platform and then it turns into
everybody that you hear from on the
right should be banned from these
platforms we need to deep platform
everyone these platforms in fact should
just become outlets for the left and
that's what the left would like that's
what the left would like this all
springs from the same attitude that says
that anything that you don't like is
dangerous to you right that any
information that you disagree with is in
effect Russian disinformation that any
information that you don't like isn't
effective incitement we saw that article
as I mentioned again yesterday for
matured stengel at former Obama
administration official who said we
should pursue hate speech laws in the
United States the home of the First
Amendment because hey people might get
offended and this is how you end up with
the stupidity over at Stanford so next
week I'm supposed to speak at Stanford
University I'm very much looking forward
to it
it's always fun I like hearing questions
from people who disagree we have a basic
rule at all of my speeches it's been
true for years if you disagree you raise
your hand you go to the front of the
line and then we have a discussion about
it and so these are open free speech
events okay and all of the posters are
being vandalized by people on the left
and hours after posting in the Nords
Elfa dorm the conservative clubs members
according to young Americans foundation
found their posters removed with a note
from Ras being put in place quote Weavin
or Delphis staff care about you and your
feelings your physical and emotional
health this is in response to the facts
that the lecture is titled facts don't
care about your feelings okay we've in
or itself of staff care about you your
feelings your physical and emotional
health this is after taking down the
poster for the event this isn't in
response it's not next to the poster for
the event it's they took down the poster
before the event and then they replaced
it with a note saying that they care
about your feelings right so I can't
think of a better metaphor than that
taking down the the poster that says
facts don't care about your feelings and
replacing it with a note that says we
care about your feelings and we do so so
much that we are going to remove
material you don't like I say you matter
and are welcome here in this space we
welcome and center the voices that some
may wish to specifically marginalize and
target and then we support black people
people of color non-binary folks LGBTQIA
folks Muslims and Jews people from
diverse backgrounds learning and
flourishing together is what makes
stanford and nord Elfa special
thank you for being you you are a star
and don't let anyone tell you you're not
please reach out to any of us if you
need to talk or need us to support you
in any way with love your nor Delphis
staff creating a generation of losers
this is how you create a generation of
losers
you say to them you don't you know what
we're not even going to allow you to see
a poster that doesn't even have any
political material on it it just says
that facts are more important than
feelings we're gonna replace that with a
poster that says you are a star lest you
be offended in some way the conservative
group apparently also attempted the EF
chapter over at Stanford also attempted
to enter Stanford's Hispanic Focus dorm
Casa de pata where they were met with a
mob of screaming leftist who hurled
expletives at the chapter members the
unhinged leftists blocked the students
from entering the dorm and followed them
to the next dorm where they intended to
poster encouraging the staff and that
building not to let them inside either
Steven sells as president of the
conservative group on campus and said a
jeering mob assembled to block us from
entering the dorm we were turned away
from the door exclusively because we
were posed during for the Ben Shapiro
lecture when I asked to see if there was
a way I could speak to a resident fellow
of the dorm I was told by one of the
residents to go suck a bleep homophobia
Wow
apparently you don't care about the
feelings there do you SILS described
that after leaving and heading over to
another dorm to poster
they'd been followed by a group of eight
students quote they shouted obscenities
heckling us and keeping us from entering
the other dorms never before have I ever
feared as much my safety on campus as I
did then the conservative students were
then accused of targeting at Casa Zapata
despite the fact that they went to a
bevy of different dorms angry leftists
discussed potential disciplinary action
against the group at a meeting with
Stanford's Provost Persis drell the
conservative group plastered nearly
every dorm of posters Tim advertised for
them by the way I'm a libertarian you
idiot I've been in favor of broadened
legal immigration for Hispanics for
years for years I'm in favor of work
permits what the hell are you even
talking about
what are you talking about I mean this
is just it's just absurd I'm sorry it's
absurd and by the way the tickets sold
out in like five seconds of course
because people actually still care about
free speech in America although the left
is doing its best to to shut it down but
it's not just the left in the United
States it's often left in Canada
Megan Murphy who was kicked off of
Twitter for the great sin of pointing
out that a man is not in fact a woman
she held a lecture in Canada and this
drove the mayor
of the town of Toronto to rip on the
library that allowed her to speak the
anti free speech movement on the left
internationally is strong and growing
much much stronger and it's happening
day in and day out because the left
doesn't like the results of free speech
because they don't like the result I
have not called for the G platforming of
anyone on the left and listen I have
significant suspicions that 2020 may not
in fact be a great year for Republicans
right the polls right now show
Republicans not doing well in the white
house in the house in the Senate right
all of that may be true I have never
called for anybody on the left to be D
platform for expressing a political
viewpoint even when I think they're
twisting the truth even when I think
they're twisting the truth because it's
my job to then reinforce what they are
saying wrong and it's their job to
fact-check me right this is everybody's
job but the goal here is to create this
you know that it's so funny what the
left will say is that they're trying to
just suss out the misinformation we have
to we have to target it we have to
destroy the misinformation but they're
not doing that instead they're
carpet-bombing the informational
distribution centers and saying
true/false doesn't matter you can't
distinguish so ever or to save this
village we need to burn it we need to
burn this free speech village in order
to save free speech right this is their
goal this is why you end up with people
tearing down posters at dorms this is
why you end up with the Toronto Mayor
John Tory who is now calling on
libraries to cancel events from Megan
Murphy a feminist who says that it's bad
for women if men who say they are women
are allowed to go into women's dressing
places and locker rooms all of this is
designed to to shut down to sent to shut
down debate by the way I'm just going to
juxtapose really fast the activity of
Toronto's mayor with activities that
took place in Minnesota last night that
apparently have received no actual
governmental talk about censorship
despite the fact that they basically
mount a child abuse
so this library in Toronto allowed Megan
Murphy to speak about the fact that men
are not women contrast that to a story
from Ann Taylor writing at caffeinated
thoughts who attended in October 17th
event at Hennepin accounts a country
library in Minnesota a taxpayer funded
event a drag queen a story our this has
become a thing in some major at
left-leaning cities apparently a drag
queen showed up wearing nude colored
underwear and proceeded to expose his
crotch to the children quote we're
talking a sleeveless
t-shirt resembling Sponge Bob
Squarepants with midriff exposed a pink
miniskirt rainbow ankle socks a black
spiked heels black spiked heels that
went about six inches the wig he wore
the drag queen was mermaid style
crimping in the color of bright orange
and the makeup that was far too much
under the neon lights the drag queen
quote strode in suggestively past the
children sitting down in a chair before
several preschool aged girls with his
legs spread wide exposing his nylon
covered crotch in front of children
sitting at eye level we noticed he did
this often while reading nervously
before the children Taylor says I
initially thought drag queen story hours
were a hoax and simply unfathomable
until I experienced one myself
apparently there are about 22 kids
ranging in age from infant toddler and
preschool into elementary grades the
library is set to host another drag
queen story hour on November 2nd now
listen I think that libraries should be
allowed to host these things I think
parents are morons for having their kids
there I think the parents are doing an
act of deep to services on our own
children by exposing them to sexualized
performance as a young age I think
that's child abuse I think that if the
library has a fun has found a way to
desexualize
a drag queen story which I don't see any
way to do that but if you find a way to
do that free speech more power to you
but the fact that the left wants to shut
down Megan Murphy for saying men are not
women but celebrates drag queens story
hour and then condemns anyone who
condemns drag queens story hour tells
you everything you need to know about
the censorious left the Hennepin County
Library told the blaze the program is
relatively new and it is unfortunately
making mistakes Oh unfortunately making
mistakes is the most story pilot
withstand performance storytime
performances involve a performer and
brilliantly colored costume in
theatrical makeup they read books and
share songs about characters who are
difference in some way and who learn to
accept and celebrate differences in
themselves and others now again I think
that there are plenty of ways that you
could do that you could dress up as a
dog and do that right but instead you're
dressing up as what is inevitably and
inherently a sexualized performance
piece when it comes to drag drag is
inherently sexualized I have yet to hear
a great argument the drag is not
inherently sexualized
I mean it just like explained the
argument to me really I'm waiting to
hear it but in any case they said
partway through this year's schedule we
realize the need for a performer dress
code we followed up right away with each
of the performers to ensure that their
costumes are appropriate for the
audience and activity now listen I think
have the prerogative not to get involved
in this drag queen story I'm parked I
think that they shouldn't I think that
parent should not take their kids to it
I think the constituency for this thing
should be zero but I'm not calling for
censors to shut down drag queens I think
that if it's child abuse if it's
sexualized and it's then again that's
that's criminal violation that's a
different thing but the fact that
libraries all over America and in Canada
are really pushing drag queens story our
butt mayors of Toronto are coming out
and saying well you know we can't have
somebody saying a man is not a woman
that tells you everything you need to
know about the censorious left they're
extending this to the social media
sphere the goal once more shut down the
dissemination of information that is
what they want because when the
dissemination of information is equal it
gives a better shot to people who are
not in the monopolistic left and the
left did have a monopoly on information
up until the last 20 years or so my
friend and mentor Andrew Breitbart used
to say that the internet was the
greatest leveling force in the history
of media which is of course why
mainstream media wants to bring all of
that back in rain all of that back in it
starts with dumb things like
fact-checking dogs being given medals by
the President and that's not where it
ends okay so it's time for a quick thing
that I like and then we'll do a quick
thing that I hate so quick thing that I
like this is kind of some fascinating
polling so there's some new polling out
that shows that President Trump is
actually running extremely competitively
with the Democrats in this race right
now but with a huge percentage of
Americans saying they don't know
according to morning consult former VP
Joe Biden only leads from 41 to 36
basically Trump is always between 36 and
between 35 and 37 percent in all of
these polls but a lot of the Democrats
have now dropped below him in these
polls because people are not sure about
these Democrats they're too radical and
they're promoting an agenda that nobody
likes Bernie Sanders is only up 39 37
which is margin of error Elizabeth
Warren is actually down 36 to 35 Kamala
Harris is down 36 to 31 Budaj edges down
35 to 29 now again that's a huge
percentage of the population that says
they don't know but that gives Trump
time to redefine himself and to find the
left which is obviously what he should
be doing today he's he should be
spending all of his time doing exactly
that okay time for a quick thing that I
hate
all right so big big story today out of
the out of Paul Sperry at real clear
investigations he apparently has
uncovered the identity of the
whistleblower who triggered this whole
Trump Ukraine thing apparently he has
identified the the person who's behind
all of this now let it be said upfront
the contents of the whistleblower report
is in and of itself troubling enough
that people should ask questions so it
doesn't discredit the actual questions
being asked who made the report but does
this appear like initially an act of
partisanship as opposed to an act of
good faith given the identity of the
whistleblower the answer is pretty
obviously yes so according to Paul
Sperry the name of the government
official fitting the description that
has been given is Eric Shira Mela I'm
gonna say his name because I don't think
that the whistleblower requires
anonymity I think that we should know
what we need to know about the people
who initiated the investigation
I don't think anonymity under these
circumstances is appropriate the name of
the government official fitting the
description eric shura mela has been
raised privately in impeachment
depositions according to officials with
direct knowledge of the proceedings
presumably this is Republicans leaking
which is bad but Democrats been leaking
too so everybody's leaking right as well
as in at least one open and hearing held
by a House committee not involved in the
impeachment inquiry fearing their
anonymous witness could be exposed
Democrats this week blocked Republicans
from asking more questions about him and
intend to redact his name from all
deposition transcripts real clear
investigations is disclosing the name
because of the public's interest in
mourning details of an effort to remove
a sitting president from office further
the official status as whistleblower is
complicated by his being a hearsay
reporter of accusations against the
president one who has some indicia of an
arguable political bias in favor of a
rival political candidate that's the
inspector community the intelligence
community Inspector General who said
this originally so what do we know about
this guy he's 33 he's a registered
Democrat held over from the Obama White
House he previously worked at both VP
Joe Biden and former on CIA director
John Brennan he's a vocal critic of
Trump further he left his national
security council posting in the White
House's West Wing in mid 2017 because
people were concerned he was leaking to
the media to the media he was then
returned to the CIA headquarters in
Langley Virginia
a former NSC official said he was
accused of working against Trump and
leaking against Trump apparently
Sharmila huddled for guidance with the
staff of House Intelligence Committee
Chairman Adam Schiff including former
colleagues also held over from the Obama
era whom Schiff had recently recruited
from the NSC and apparently charmella
also worked with the DNC operative who
dug up dirt on Trump during the 2016
election inviting her into the White
House for meetings according to former
White House colleagues that operative
alexandra chalupa is Ukrainian American
who supported Hillary and led an effort
to link the Republican campaign to the
Russian government he knows her he had
her in the White House and one former
coworker who requested anonymity to
discuss the sensitive matter documents
confirm that she actually attended at
least one White House meeting with chair
Mela in November of 2015 so this has
been you know this is obviously deeply
troubling because it does go to motive
right again it looks like basically a
person who hated Trump who was waiting
for the opportunity to jump on the
bandwagon of a problem and then blow it
up to epic proportions this wasn't
somebody who was like well everything is
going fine here and you know I'm gonna
wait for a legit crime in order to make
a fuss instead it was somebody who
apparently was colluding with Adam chef
in order to come up with this entire
whistleblower allegation it was somebody
who was a an ardent Joe Biden defender
which is why he found this so
inappropriate now does this answer all
the questions about impeachment of
course not of course not it doesn't
answer the questions about whether
Trump's activity on that call was
appropriate whether Trump was in fact
leveraging American taxpayer dollars to
specifically go after a twenty20
political rival without evidence and
without any concern for corruption it
doesn't answer those questions and Trump
will have to answer those questions but
it's certainly going to lend a lot of
credence to Trump's allegation that this
entire thing from the beginning was
cooked up by a Democrat and somebody
inside the Quorum quote deep state who's
seeking to selectively leaked
information to harm Trump because
apparently that's what this guy did
according to Paul Sperry reporting for
real clear investigations we will bring
you more on that this afternoon I am
sure when we get to our two additional
hours of content I'm Ben Shapiro this is
the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Robert Sterling directed by Mike joiner
executive producer Jeremy boring senior
producer Jonathan hey our supervising
producer is Mathis Glover and our
technical producer is Austin Stevens
assistant director Pavo white house key
edited by Adam Tsai events audio is
mixed by Mike Carmina hair and makeup is
by Jessica all Vera production assistant
Nick Sheehan the Ben Shapiro show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
president Trump tweets that a dog meme
and the mainstream media lose their
collective minds we will explain why
fanatics never laugh and how democracy
dies in bark nests
check it out on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]